on Thursday a Colorado civic group
expressed interest in buying the Denver
Post newspaper with investors already
pledging 10 million dollars in funds the
potential bid came after a rare revolt
at the paper outraged after he had
another round of layoffs post employees
called the papers hedge fund owners in
the pages of the paper itself saying
that their budget cuts are destroying
the good journalism that the community
relies on from Denver Barry Petersen has
a story the Sunday editorial pullout
section of the Denver Post was an act of
defiance and desperation I felt like we
call out other people who we feel like
aren't doing their job or living up to
their obligations we should be able to
call out our landowners and that's what
I did it what was the post at its peak
in terms of reporters and editors how
many yeah when I started here there were
like more than 300 editorial page editor
Chuck Plunkett and a host of other
writers criticized the papers hedge fund
owners Alden global capital for slashing
staff and they warned Denver it may lose
its century-and-a-half old newspaper
most of us think of newspapers as things
that are losing money is that true he'll
media experts nationally and locally
have reported that Aldens making profit
of around 20 percent
that's another compelling reason to go
with a editorial like this and let our
readers know hey it's not this narrative
that we're going down the tubes because
we can't pay the bills isn't completely
the narrative that you need to have in
mind there's something else going on
here too the striking perspective
section included a photo filled with
silhouettes those are the journalists
who were laid off or have left since the
paper would a Pulitzer Prize in 2013 the
various article said the papers ranks
have shriveled to around 60 placing
blame squarely on what one writer called
the vulture capitalist at the hedge fund
when we had the meeting about you know
announcing the 30 layoffs there there
was so much silence in that room you
could hear a pin drop
and looking around the room and
especially at the young reporters in the
young editors you know they were crying
because they didn't know what was gonna
happen I'm gonna miss it a lot for John
label The Denver Post was the only
journalism home he had ever known his
career started in the photo lab at age
19 and over the next three decades as a
sports photographer labor would capture
memorable moments for the paper until
Monday his last day at the post
what does Denver and the region going to
miss having a diminished and some worry
maybe not even having a denver post I
think they're gonna miss a great deal of
love for what people do for that
newspaper you know I've been getting
calls from everybody that you know
they're gonna stop their subscription
because they're not gonna be seeing my
my stuff in the paper anymore or
anything like that
Alden global capital is the primary
equity holder in digital first media
which owns 97 newspapers according to
the news guild Union some papers have
lost more than 70 percent of their
workforce a recent lawsuit alleges Alden
mismanaged hundreds of millions of
dollars from the news chain now Plunkett
is hoping community and civic leaders
will react to the editorial section and
step in to save the flagship local
newspaper this Sunday Plunkett plans to
publish letters from readers offering
support like this one that says there
can be no true democracy without a free
press critics will be heard to like this
reader who wrote The Denver Post is
reaping what it has sowed the editorial
arrogance and left bias has rendered it
irrelevant when you think of the good
that a large newsroom can do that paper
of record role that watchdog role that
function that we provide you speak truth
to power you provide a voice to the
voiceless you try to matter in your
community and you try to help your
community achieve its goals and it's
about and live up to its values and
losing that would be such a tremendous
loss for CBS this morning Saturday Barry
Petersen Denver
Walden global capital did not respond to
our repeated requests for comment it's
not easy Anthony to push back the hand
that feeds you know it these are very
painful times at newspapers you know
both for the owners and for the
especially for the employees as we saw
that the numbers and staff reductions
are just astounding but you know they're
right these many of these papers have
had critical roles in their communities
and there's it's gonna be really hard to
replace interesting to see the ten
million dollars the Civic group is
putting forward exactly where that goes
and that gets traction yeah I hope
something happens there